oui l'allemagne on le disait de loin le
pays le plus accueillant mais ce n'est
pas suffisant l'union européenne doit
faire plus son président veut d'ailleurs
forcé les pays membres à se répartir cet
afflux de réfugiés vrai qu'en fait les
derniers chiffres donnent le vertige aux
autorités européennes
effectivement en fait les chiffres qui
ont été publiés aujourd'hui par le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés donc à l'onu
estiment que dans les prochains mois il
y aura en fait 850 mille réfugiés donc
mis 150 migrants qui vont partir
traversé la méditerranée pour arriver en
europe
évidemment on comprend qu'il ya quand
même certaines craintes en europe
par contre le président de la commission
européenne se dit bon ben il faut se
retrousser les manches nous il faudrait
que nos pays membres soit prêt à en
accueillir 160 milles alors sur les 160
millions à 40 milles qui sont déjà
arrivées ce printemps les autres îles
120000 sont actuellement en hongrie en
grèce et en italie
alors évidemment ça plaît pas à tout le
monde ça fait grincer des dents il ya
certains pays qui refusent les chiffres
qui leur sont proposées pour de
multiples raisons d'ailleurs mais
comment est-ce que là on établit cette
répartition justement on va essayer en
fait de minimiser l'impact quand même
parce que c'est un afflux assez
important donc on a évalué sa en
fonction par exemple de la richesse du
pays donc selon par exemple le pib le
produit intérieur brut selon la taille
de la population selon également le
nombre moyen de demandeurs d'asile
et puis aussi le taux de chômage parce
qu'il faut pas se le cacher c'est quand
même une donnée importante quand il ya
beaucoup de monde qui entrent sur le
marché du travail prochainement en
échange et bien les pays qui
accueilleront un migrant es bien
recevront une aide de 9700 dollars
environ par personne de l'union
européenne de l'union européenne bien
sûr bon évidemment il ya ce côté plus
officielle mais il ya aussi beaucoup
d'initiatives plus personnel de citoyens
un peu comme on a vu ici d'ailleurs
effectivement et le danemark vous savez
on en fait l'immigrant là bas sont
persona non grata donc il ya certains
citoyens danois qui ont décidé vraiment
de faire un effort et donc on quand on
voit tous et toutes ces images en fait
de migrants qui sont sont les la route
vers la suède et bien il ya énormément
de citoyens qui apportent des
couvertures de la nourriture des jouets
pour les enfants également du côté de
strasbourg par exemple vous savez il ya
des députés qui ont proposé de vous
savez on a un parlement européen mais on
siège à peu près 50 jours par année on à
750 bureaux qui sont quasiment vides
toute l'année on a des 12
migros exactement pourquoi pas ne pas
accueillir temporairement ces migrants
et puis il ya aussi les fameux club de
football les clubs de soccer en europe
qui évidemment sont très populaire là
bas ils en ont décidé de donner aussi un
petit coup de pouce aux migrants et donc
par exemple paris saint germain va
verser paris saint germain va verser un
million et demi de dollars pour aider
ces gens là et la plupart des clubs de
football en fait en europe ont décidé
également d'offrir de verser 1 dollar 50
par biens qui seront vendus lors des
grosses compétitions et qui s'en
viennent bientôt donc chacun essaye d'y
aller un petit peu selon selon leur
échelle vient ramener les enfants de
réfugiés aussi insolite que ça existe un
beau petit coup aussi humain là c'est
apporter justement montré que ces
migrants un visage
et puis il faut quand même faire
attention à ça sent les moyens c'est que
en plus merci beaucoup